[Music]
a lot of founders worry about the optics
of profitability because they're told to
but they misunderstand the timing like
you should not [ __ ] your pants when
you're 57 but you definitely are allowed
to p you know [ __ ] your pants when
you're one
and i think a lot of companies start
making these decisions at one and two
years old
that don't make sense for a one or two
year old company
you've got your perspective
[Applause]
i just want to be happy don't you want
to be happy
hi gary how are you i'm wamasha how are
you amazing so this is our second
[ __ ] fridays uh on a thursday first
you know that's gonna be another
thursday uh where we talk to founders
and give them relevant advice on exactly
what's happening right now we had a
great first episode uh last week and i'm
excited to see the founders that uh that
join us this week
i agree i thought the episode went
extremely well let's give a huge shout
out to everybody in the linkedin family
out there
uh let's take a look here mcmahon and
milan and chris juan and isaac and este
rob great to see all of you keep the
comments coming your questions insights
justin long's in the building
um
a real fun part of this show is the live
linkedin community that watches along
with us
um lizette good to see you susan um so
yeah i'm really excited i thought the
level of conversation was very high
level
um and uh i'm excited about it
and
michelle's face is frozen for me so i
will continue to talk
um producers if you guys want to jump in
i'm just going to talk and say hi to
ollie and johnny evereed and samuel
and dana jacobson
um and uh
and omar great to see you
come olaf great to see you there you are
there i am i don't know what happened
there like a little network problem it
looked like it looks like we're back
though
yes i was just saying hello to everybody
who's tuned in on linkedin please
everybody on linkedin hit the share take
the url right now and share it on
twitter and other places um really
really fun but let's get into it
yeah let's get into it so
would love to bring on our first guest
anna peterson uh the ceo of the animals
wow
hello how are you
i'm so great how are you guys
good would love to uh
a quick you know 30 second pitch on uh
on doing your business
yeah sure so i created a screen free
meditation device by our first product
was for children it's in the shape of a
little turtle that plays mind-guided
meditations at the press of button and
three sleep soundtracks um it's an fda
approved uh food grade silicone shell so
it's a super safe product it's removable
the shell is dishwasher safe there's a
speaker and an earphone jack for audio
options
hospitals schools and
other institutions are instilling them
as programs
for mindfulness and social emotional
learning for children and then recently
just launched a teen and adult device
um so those are going into general
hospitals uh and we hope to branch out
into the military and the and the
nursing home community as well
that's amazing and it's like it sounds
like you've made it a million dollar
business already i have i have it was
amazing i was um
telling some of the other people
backstage it was i i officially started
marketing in march of 2020 and uh it was
an
unbelievable time in the world and and
just being there for people was a really
magical experience and
quite overwhelming there was a huge
sense of responsibility that i felt and
um and then also being there i support
uh five percent of the profits go to
precious dreams foundation and
that was like they were instrumental
last year in helping children in foster
care and um so being a part of that
conversation as well was was matt it's
been it's been wonderful as as horrible
as the last however many months we've
been doing this now yeah ben i think
it's been
pretty magical for for the mental health
space and bringing awareness to you know
the fact that even pre-pandemic the
second leading cause of death for kids
age 10 to 14 was suicide this was pre
pandemic like this was a conversation we
should have been having
five ten years ago um we're a little
late you know and so i think i guess
better late than never but but happy
again just to to be here and be a part
of it
that's awesome
so what are your questions for us today
yeah so i am still running the show by
myself i have no full-time employees um
and so i i have a lot of great
consultants in place for accounting i
have a great 3pl and so i think my
biggest pain point right now is b2b
sales that's been really difficult
trying to build that team but also
supply chain i do manufacture in china
and as you all know like that's that has
come with some severe difficulties this
year and so i guess my question would be
what do you who do you think my first
hire should be at this stage in my game
so i can weigh in first and then uh
we're gonna see what gary has to say so
i think uh for me you actually want to
look for like a true
second line to you jack of all trades
that can figure out anything not afraid
to get their hands dirty that you can
build that level of trust with um it's
great that you've used like consultants
and key areas like you know jack of all
trades is not your best accountant
but really like this is a super hard
part for every founder where they
realize that they cannot infinitely
scale themselves and it's really hard
and it's really stressful where every
customer service email every time a
problem happens and so that that person
sometimes takes a little a hard time to
find but they're someone that wants to
they're willing to build a business you
should be willing to give them a piece
of equity if they turn out really well
um but that is like so so so critical
and i actually meet a lot of founders
that get to you know a couple million
dollars in sales i i actually met one
recently was about 10
and just could not take herself out of
the business and you just hit this point
where you cannot get any bigger unless
you can learn to trust other folks so
it's a critical point uh if you get
around the first time remember that you
you can certainly move on and hire
someone else because i know it's scary
but that's uh that's what i would say
that's great
amazing um and for me i think yes i
agree with everything michelle said i
think there's a lot of validity there
what what are you
worse that and or what do you most
dislike if i ask you right now
what do you most dislike
in your week to week forget about day to
day because i don't think that's
consistent enough like you know like
in a month like what do you just
genuinely not like out of all the things
what do you not like
that's a it's an awesome question i
think on any given day i think there
there are many things i of course
i love development but the supply chain
i find very very stressful um those
logistics
are tough i think financials it's i
don't like it probably because i'm not
super good at it and it takes me a lot
of time and i'm a very i love efficiency
and it that takes me extra time to
understand and grasp and so i get
frustrated there so probably
probably financials and and supply chain
are my
things that i could probably do without
that
that's your hire okay
if you're lucky enough to find somebody
who can do both which is not
inconceivable people go into court
people go into corporate mindset
be
too fast when they're small right like
you're doing a ton of things on paper i
don't know what i don't know you i don't
know what you were doing before but on
paper
it might have not seemed like you could
or should do all these things but you do
have a necessity right when you start a
company
i i think i would look for somebody for
supply chain
yeah
and then
literally interview and like literally
post on linkedin and say i'm looking for
supply chain
comma
small company house like are you an
accountant by trade or like
you they're just a there's a like this
concept that people are one thing is
very corporate right and startup land
like everything
chief everything officer the ceo
i think you can find somebody who does
supply chain and finances
okay
i'm convinced you can i actually think
that they have a lot of similarities
from a human and so i think that
straight man or woman is exactly who
you're looking for okay
awesome
great
um and then
oh my second question um so i haven't
taken any outside funding to date do you
guys think at this stage that it's worth
giving up some equity to be able to
scale
quickly to build an entire team and and
do do the bigger things and throw you
know some more at marketing than i'm
that i'm currently doing you know
risking you know some bouts of of
you know lack of profitability and
things like that do you think
that is that would be a wise move or not
quite yet
michelle i think this is so in your zone
and then i'll follow up
yeah sure
um
you know look i'm i'm biased right the
whole reason we built clear co is
because i believe that when you do the
work as the founder you should own your
company because the reality is is that
um investors are going to put in money
they're going to do absolutely nothing
to build your business and you are going
to be left doing all of the work and so
it doesn't seem like you're giving up
much in the early days it's like oh i'm
giving up 5 or 10 or 25 of my company
and it can be so much bigger but my gut
is that you'll be successful i mean if
you took something from idea to product
to prototype to a million sales like
most people
never
ever ever get there and so
on
in
and that's really problematic when you
don't feel like you control your own
destiny when people that don't have the
same information you have are telling
you to make decisions on your business
and so we're a big fan of obviously
being able to use capital so you can
still invest more into marketing you
could still um you know be feeling that
growth but at the end of the day you
know paying six percent for that capital
versus you know giving up a piece of
control in your company that being said
there are amazing investors out there if
you have someone super value-add i
suggest you doing a ton of homework it's
like a marriage with no sex so you
should really like that person before
starting to work with them and really
understand that they want to spend the
kind of time and it won't be the same as
you but but they want to spend true time
and true thought um building your
business
that's great you said something that
really caught my attention i don't think
businesses should really worry about
profitability besides making payroll and
paying their bills
unless they are on the precipice
of
selling and are
going for that
or
there's some erroneous events in that
human being's life where they just need
the money and i don't mean
i need a second home or i need a test i
need a tesla right so
i think um
a lot of founders worry about the optics
of profitability because they're told to
but they misunderstand the timing like
you should not [ __ ] your pants when
you're 57 but you definitely are allowed
to p you know [ __ ] your pants when
you're one
and i think a lot of companies start
making these decisions at one and two
years old
that don't make sense for a one or
two-year-old company right
like
i
spent most of my time trying to make
vaynermedia and wine library my two
family businesses my family business and
my business
as little profit as possible because i
want to pour back in to build as big of
a business as possible sure
yeah so like when you know you know hurt
profitability or things that need you
know like
if you're you're not that means you're
playing defense at such a young age yeah
yeah
the other thing that
i would um the last thing i would share
anna is that
you know i was a bootstrapped
entrepreneur for the first 10 years of
my career got lucky enough to sell one
of my companies to groupon and it was
the only reason i got to build other
things is that i actually you know i had
two co-founders i owned a third of the
company we had a 10 esop pool
honest
i remember doing the math and even if we
had raised a seed round or a series a
like you're looking for a 25 50 million
outcome because again your investors get
their money back first right so if you
get a million dollars into your business
and your business only sells for a
million bucks they get all their money
back and you are left with nothing and
there is a true downside case and so it
also just depends on your personality
type like for me i wanted to know my
downside case is like okay like i still
have a third of this business right
um and uh and that that really did
matter to me but i think it was it was
game changing in my career uh that i was
able to retain you know equity at an
early age and i get it you can
it's just a much higher risk path uh to
take another move and i actually think
there are there now are capital sources
available that can allow you to grow uh
without doing that yeah that's amazing
that's great cool
i like what
anna what what's the biggest difference
right this minute in the consumer
part than when you launched with success
competitive landscape demand evolution
staleness um
like you know growth like what's the
biggest difference right now on the
consumer lens
like is the map
yeah i think if i understand the
question correctly i think learning that
this is a seasonal product which i think
is the strangest way
yeah fast even though people buy
meditation apps i i i it's i don't know
i don't i don't know if it's the price
point or if it's because it's a physical
product but it's very like summer was
very very slow people were traveling
like kids were staying up late parents
didn't care that they were having
problems sleeping because they could
sleep in and you know during the day
um as soon as school started back up it
was like the moon again
um chris holidays are bananas
which is like that was a new game for me
that i realized last year i was not
anticipating that at all there's a lot
of ebb and flow throughout the year and
i think it was this is this is where
marketing really really really really
matters yes
and in two ways doubling down on key
moments right and then a lot of
companies go cold when they think it's
not season this is where i completely
exploded my dad's business
people would restart marketing in
september and october yeah and i i
marketed like crazy in july and august
and my dad was freaked out yeah because
i was building awareness for september
yeah
so
right so like if you start doing content
in mid-july
that says things in the copy like
hey click it for a calendar reminder to
make sure on august 30th you're ready to
like buy our product like just notice
how clever and like how you're like like
just that yeah just a piece of content
like does your kid sleep well
and then like here's a calendar i know
literally you're being empathetic to
them the copy is
i know you guys in the summer enjoy it
staying up late sleep in
click this link to put this in your
google calendar
for september 1st to make sure you you'd
be stunned what kind like that
that's so cool
i think so yeah there you go what i
think i didn't get here with my look
santa
this is the [ __ ] i do
it's really it's about things like that
i also hear your neck and i also think
content from your customers is huge yeah
i think
i think you should send an email out to
everybody who ever bought and said
if you make a tick tock with our product
please email it here and randomly some
of you will xyz yeah
yeah tick tock is not it's not a
platform that we're on yet and i am like
a bang in my head against the wall
trying to get that going because i think
it's a huge mystery you need you need to
do that immediately you're one you're
one tick tock away one one random tuck
that you're not even thinking about away
from having a totally different business
yeah
yeah the amount i mean tic tocs
explosion is 38 to 50 right now yeah
it's unbelievable i think and that's and
that's where like i think bandwidth
comes in and things like that but this
just needs to go to the top of the list
and like the other the other thing that
companies make a mistake on is they
don't realize the moment
tick-tock virality to get 12 million
views on a video is going to go away in
24 months and you're going to miss the
window correct yeah
yeah yeah no it's uh absolutely
absolutely well
i'm sorry michelle i apologize anna you
need to you need to prioritize that to
number one anything that allows you for
brand explosion
at high upside low
investment yeah brand not sales
brand explosion high upside low
investment needs to be the number one
thing you prioritize yeah
and because it's not a sales conversion
for a dtc brand tick tock is down the
totem pole
right
because people think people thinking
conversion
yeah
i definitely do yeah
awesome
all right that's great advice okay so
you you you have a few ideas around new
hires around tick tocks around which
would be the top of the priority list
and uh and we're wishing you all the
best luck thank you thank you both so
much i really hold on anna real quick
william patrick in the comments
it says i'm your guy for supply chain
travel there it is
amazing thank you
i will
i will i will
awesome
thank you guys cheers cheers bye
okay
that was fun that was really fun that
was really fun i as a quick interlude
here i heard your nft was sold at
christie's this week
tomorrow tomorrow
that's exciting tomorrow my five
original five of my original drawings
are being sold
so not the nfts like curio cards and art
blocks the actual art yeah
i am an artist
you are an old expert you can use your
best sharpies you did them
i'm an artist let's keep going
that's amazing good thank you we're all
we're all cheering on great okay we got
lindsey
have you on lindsay
hello everyone so nice to meet you both
this is just an honor thank you so much
for having me i really appreciate it
lindsey i think uh michelle was chopping
when she introduced you so maybe you can
introduce the company one more time and
then we'll just go in here sure i'm
lindsay with green wallscapes we create
um preserved moss walls and ship them
all over the us and canada
we do projects um we'll do probably
about 300 to 350 projects this year um
some like the size beside behind me you
know small lots of different designs we
also do work with succulents and other
things like that what's great and the
solution that we've created um
completely by accident by the way um is
no watering no special light
requirements so it works really well um
in
uh
part of the homes yeah and homes and
homes and offices all over the place so
it looks beautiful thank you that means
so much to me wow how much are how much
are they um they all there's a price per
square foot where they range um so like
the pieces behind me each one of these
is about eight hundred dollars um
because they're all
you know custom handmade yeah yeah
beautiful
but then we also have where we really
make our money is
large-scale commercial applications of
materials so
um we've worked with companies like
starbucks and stella artois and like a
lot of major uh huge real estate
development firms and things like that
uh we do their lobbies we do you know
all sorts of different tenant
improvement spaces and things like that
so we have you know just me and my
my four team members um have done work
with some crazy brands we like we can't
even believe it sometimes
good for you
yeah yeah
um and so anyway i wanted to ask you
guys some questions about
um hiring and retaining talent in this
very tight market
um what we do there's no school there's
no moss school so we want to
train people um but they have to have
sort of an aesthetic eye they have to
have um and they also have to be okay
with like physical
um you know labor there's a lot of
lifting and moving and all that kind of
stuff that goes with you need you need
to make an incredibly smart upfront
filter for applicants you should have a
page on your site where you and your
team have an incredible video that's two
three minutes long where you really go
deep into this okay and then a series of
like 15 to 20 very specific questions
you you need to filter out people
got it you need to like really it's
about it's about being vulnerable and
authentic
like this was something i really
struggled with for a long time i you
know because i would just blast out like
come work at vaynermedia and then
everybody would come but i didn't put
them in a position to really filter
themselves out
you need to like really go there and
like be self-deprecating and fun with it
like and you need to do physical labor
and then like somebody's then you click
on you know then the sh the video shows
one of you
one of the people working on it carrying
and they turn like this stuff's heavy
you know like
you need to like give everybody
i i think the video in itself could
become a marketing tool god willing it
goes a little viral but i think that's
like when you're that specific
i think that you know travis says higher
recruiter i'm not a fan of that as much
though i love recruiters and i'm sure
there's plenty that'll be great at it
i'm a huge fan
of a heavy filter that's very unique to
you
based on the very big uniqueness
that's a really good idea and um it will
work
yeah by the way and then the first thing
i would do once that page is up is email
it to everybody who bought the product
oh okay oftentimes some of the best
early employees are early customers of
the thing totally
oh interesting interesting
um
and then um so i wanted to ask you just
to sort of change gears here for a
second
um
so right now everything we do is custom
so there's some limitations with that
because you know how long it takes to
get the moss and some other things like
that
should we be looking at
repeatable non-custom moss art options
right now like i mean currently right
now i'm completely sold out until the
end of the year almost um and everyone's
like oh hire more employees but with the
supply chain challenges right now it's
really hard
hard um so have you thought have you
thought about are you able to pre-sale
yes yes everything is pre-sold
oh even better i mean
as long as you make promises to
customers one of the biggest changes i
made to my dad's business was we
pre-sold wine sometimes that was coming
out 18 months later
oh that's interesting now that was a
standard practice in the wine business
it was called futures right you would
buy the new bordeaux year before it was
even bottled maybe a little bit less
standard in your world but i will say
authenticity always plays you as the
founder
right even just you're like you know
you're just extremely bubbly and
positive and like have really like
your video just saying hey you know on
the product page hey
supply chain sure you're all aware this
is just going to be six months out
because of that we're even being more
aggressive with the price here
i i think pre-selling
is something that people are
underestimating in this moment in time
right yeah i mean
we have deposits till the end of the
year already so it's you know the other
thing is when you're selling at that
level your pricing might be too low
yeah
it's really not that's what's shocking
it really it really it really doesn't
have everything have gone through the
roof right now i think engine is closer
to 40
linz i think you're missing something
very important
um
it's really not because you may be
premium in your category you just might
not realize how premium your brand is
okay i i thank you
you understand just because you're just
because you're 800 bucks and all your
competitors are 500 cartier doesn't
worry about what other people sell their
rings for nike doesn't worry what other
brands you might have just
put yourself in a position where you are
not maximizing your float
in the difference between you and other
brands there's a lot of agencies that
don't cost a million dollars to get out
of bed but we do you know and so like
right but then they get to talk to you
gary and that's what's so exciting
that's that's right that's that's that's
that's right but i mean i think that's
that's the biggest point here right like
clearly you've done something
that may
uh have also created that incredible
brand arbitrage and i think that's
remarkable and i would not be
scared to try
listen one thing one thing i can tell
you as somebody who sold things since he
was five years old selling flowers at
door to door
you can always lower your price
that is true
yeah
and and just remember the incredible
testing infrastructure of out there do
one drop of the exact same thing say you
have exactly 500 units and see if they
sell out in a day like when you create
this brand on like limited quantities
it's like great people want a custom
piece and then they might want three
more walls in their house that are done
by that like just just don't be afraid
of that testing and i actually think i i
really like the idea of even testing
higher prices honestly i think the
market is crazy right now and there is
almost insatiable um
you know
these governments printed unlimited cash
like we have to recalibrate the world
yeah america printed america printed 15
of all the money it's ever printed but
it's history in its i didn't finish it
gets crazier in its history 15 or 14 or
definitely over 10 and below 20
percent of all the money it's printed in
the history of america in an 18-month
period during covent
that money's in the system now
right
and so if blueberries are
up by double then why can't a moss paint
you know
picture go from 800 to 1300 or at least
9.99
which is that last dollar before the
mental threshold of a thousand
okay
it's worth trying absolutely absolutely
try it out and post it share share your
story on social we'll we'll keep
commenting and we want to see how it
goes
awesome thank you so much can i ask you
one more question
yeah one more
um so
you know i have a small team right now i
love my team they're my rider dies and
that's so awesome
there i'm starting to see like for us to
really be able to take it to where i
want to go
we're going to need to bring some more
hires and it's going to change um the
environment probably um
how do you guys balance like good vibes
millennial
you know feel goodness with sort of
profitability and you know having to
stay on the sort of business and numbers
side of things um because i find
sometimes
i'm a little too soft on one um and it
impacts the other
the right to be profitable or the
ability to be profitable gives you the
right to do whatever the [ __ ] you want
and that's what you have to keep telling
your team is that when when we're
profitable we have the luxury of being
able to launch new products build new
things support the charities we want
support each other like that doesn't
exist if this business is not profitable
and is not making money and
and that
people actually understand when you give
them reality i i even think the most
dreamy millennials when you look at them
dead in the whites of their eyes and
you're like you know this is the reality
of of how this is going to shake out and
this is why this is the most important i
mean i tell our team all the time what
we're doing is very hard we're creating
a new asset class we have a lot of
people that are in the system that are
rigged against us this is i you didn't
come here because this was going to be
easy and reminding people that they can
do hard things that they were built for
hard teams they have a team that cares
about them that there's a lot of
kindness around them like that
i i think that is that is what happens
but don't let people because then other
people start controlling the narrative
in your company and you know this exists
because you built it and you dreamt it
and you've kept the thing profitable and
and if they understand that you actually
stop as soon as you set that standard
you have a lot less of these
conversations and it becomes actually a
lot easier
okay
my take on that is yes
comma um
[Music]
i
call vaynerx the honey empire
i believe in honey over vinegar i
believe in kindness
i believe in
all good feelings all the time because
people go faster
when you're worried about the politics
you go slow
i believe that business is completely
misunderstood i don't believe in sharp
elbows i i don't think that being kind
means you're a pushover
um i think what you need to make sure is
that your candor is on point a weakness
of mine for 20 years
so what you do what you need to be
careful of is is the cat is creating
you know entitlement
because you're not cancerous along with
the kindness
and the other thing that you have to
remember is
whether you're four people or 4 000
people one human being can change the
culture you've got to cut out cancer
when you observe it
right so
don't be scared about going from how
many are you at
well so we're at four four and we're
going to hire probably three to four
more
four four to eight is a piece of cake to
keep everything you want
it just might mean that you need to fire
person number six
three weeks in to their tenure mm-hmm
don't be scared of the hiring the hiring
is guessing
right
the firing is knowing
[Music]
yeah 100
which is also one of my least favorite
i'm like can i hire somebody who will
just fire people for me because that is
my least favorite
by the way you absolutely can um
human that it's hard to fire people you
should never want to take that trait
away from yourself that's the it's the
worst thing but for me i hated it but i
will tell you without a shadow of doubt
my core weakness in 25 years was the
lack of candor that led to me surprise
firing people once i finally got that up
yeah
awkwardness please please please either
you could absolutely hire somebody to
fire make somebody your number two and
make her him in charge of operational
hiring and firing and then
sally or
rick will do the firing and you'll tell
them to i did it for years then i wanted
to develop it but for years i was like
dad you need to fire that person bobby
my cousin that wine library fire that
person aj fired up like so you know and
and eventually i realized it was too
much of a vulnerability to not have the
ability to be candarous i added the word
kind to it and now kind candor has set
me free and made me a better operator
yeah because i think that the
entitlement thing i i do kind of go back
and forth with that a little bit you
know because sometimes i feel like well
i'm being so gentle that i'm not getting
what the business is that's that's
exactly what is possible and what you
need to do is call a five-person kind
camera meeting
okay
be vulnerable ladies gentlemen i find
myself being too kind
and i'm starting to build subconscious
and now it's conscious resentment
towards some of you or sometimes on how
we roll i don't want to be that person i
don't want to do that to you
um
this is what i'm going to need maybe in
my baby steps to being more candace i'm
going to send a friday email and
observations
the tone is positive i'll put a bottle
of jihad emojis and so this
vulnerability this this vulnerability
and honesty
is an incredibly powerful opportunity
yeah and it's and i think that you have
to change your mindset to actually
believe it's cruel to not tell the truth
it's cruel to actually not tell people
where they stand and how they're doing
i think yeah but michelle i'm sort of
interrupt but karina z said i think it's
more kind to be blatantly honest about
employee performance right the problem
is
blatantly
radical candor versus kind candor
like like
what ends up happening is people end up
delivering it poorly oh yeah you can't
be an [ __ ] man and you're no no one's
gonna even listen they're just gonna be
hurt
comma if you go straight
straight not [ __ ]
yeah but if you go straight
there will be inherent fear
and fear is poison yeah it is poison and
we really don't do that but yes
but it requires candor hence kind candor
you have to come with compassion
points of view you know
and and people's you know again bruce
says clear is kind sure
you may feel like you are clear but you
have to be empathetic and compassionate
to how one receives it if somebody was
parented in a way where they over
cuddled everything
any level of clear
proper feedback is perceived as a
negative
we have to be compassionate to this
well gary i i have to say i've been
following you for like literally 10
years and this is like so amazing thank
you so much for your time i really mean
it's like me so much well i'm so happy
to get to know you and and it's just
been so wonderful thank you guys both
you're very sweet thank you and lindsay
can you do me a favor can you send me an
email to gary at vaynermedia and say i
was just on the show with you michelle
i'd like to buy a moss thing and hang it
up
that means so much thank you guys both
so i'm sorry we're getting emotional
this is just a really big deal
it's
amazing i'm playing
big hugs thanks lindsay
that was awesome i mean what an
incredible story and i think it's you
know super important discussion about
how you have to deal with some of the
harder things in business that people
don't want to talk about they want to
talk about everything going well they
don't talk about the days that we have
underperformers and the days that things
are not working and how to deliver those
messages but um
let's take some questions from the
audience
you've got a system for this michelle oh
there we go
any advice for an administrator with
creative leanings without an outlet to
explore these dreams
um i don't know i got i got a big one
greg i really really really really think
greg
side hustle you've got to start an nft
project
please please i'll tell you why
god forbid aka
slang term for god willing
one nft collector or influencer finds a
liking to it you could be a full-time
artist in five minutes
if you are creative that way
um in visual form video
yeah drawing sketching doodling please
go that route if it's a different
creative essence
look for companies like vaynermedia we
hire people in creative that have no
creative background they come from
administrative they come from the
concrete business they come from sales
there are optimistic curious companies
out there find them
oh there's another good uh question how
can a small business in the custom
apparel business that can't afford the
dev work for smart contracts embrace
nfgs
by putting out a tweet with the hashtag
nft and finding somebody who's willing
to take a piece of the action to do the
tech work for three free matt there's a
ton of those people
yeah i love you get involved get
involved in discords matt put in the
groundwork like i did when i was
starting wine library tv hours and hours
of groundwork on twitter and discord you
will find tons of devs to do it for free
yeah okay next one um just getting
started not free excuse me just for
clarity they'll take a piece of the
action they'll say matt i want 10 of the
initial sales in the royalties
yeah and that's fair because honestly
this is not going to get off the ground
unless you do it
um so i got another one just getting out
of um
started in the supply chain business and
due to container shortages facing some
difficulties how to keep yourself going
through some of these toughest times in
your business okay rowhead uh container
prices are absolutely out of control i
mean from three grand i've seen canada
prices at fifteen to twenty thousand
dollars there is no simple way these are
going to come down because ports are
full shipping containers are full and
unless you have massive volumes it's
extremely difficult to negotiate right
now um and so i i think it is
figuring out a way to beg borrow and
steal and see if you can actually solve
the problem seeing if you can look for
manufacturing
um
in other places but it's actually i
think your question is a little bit
different which is like how as an
entrepreneur do you pick yourself up
when you're down and for me it's always
actually listening to other
entrepreneurs understanding that like
even what seemed to be the most
successful businesses almost failed like
20 times as they were being built
and uh and then having that circle of
friends and founders uh and other people
that are building businesses that can be
like yeah i mean i'm in the same
show as you are so here's either my
ideas or here's how i can solve it but i
think you know misery loves company and
that that group of my own
entrepreneurial friends has been
critical uh i also think i also think
there's moments in time where you can't
do anything
yeah
like
you know a global pandemic came along
like i don't care how good of a business
woman or man you were what in europe
when world war ii broke out your
business wasn't as good
right like that's just real life
and so we are living through a global
pandemic where the
small group of shipping companies have
finally used this moment to create much
more margin
and the walmarts and the costco's and
things that nature have lost their
leverage and
you know michelle you're more educated
maybe
not maybe in this than i am
i don't think containers are coming down
anytime soon they are not they are not
all
this infrastructure is not there for
these to come down that's right so this
could be it
i mean maybe they go down from 15 and 20
to 10 and 12 but the days of three have
no rationale to come back unless
governments regulate
and so
which they have no incentive to do and
no right it's kind of like it's kind of
like it's cut it's pressuring like it's
not gonna happen it's just that's right
it's dealing with uh dealing with your
business
so what that's gonna do is it's gonna
lead to india
and the us and parts of europe and other
parts of the world to probably start
really aggressively on the 10-year plan
10-year plan building out manufacturing
i think people are
you know it's okay this is when you
pivot
you know michelle's point is absolutely
well taken
but
the misery loves company when your
business is never going back to that
place is a you know e-commerce came out
it happened
which meant you're never going back to
just having leverage as a big box
retailer yeah like that's like
you know and so containers are here to
stay at high prices wrap your head
around that and decide what you're gonna
do
okay i thought we were wrapping up but
we got one more what trends do you see
in a post ios 14 world when it was
harder to reach customers um
i'm gonna go real fast and i'll let you
wrap up the show i think people are
gonna have to get better than just doing
math arbitrage on facebook and instagram
how about that
uh you know like yes i understand you
can't read cookie and read people got
very lazy it was easy to build a dtc
brand yeah facebook instagram at scale
big brands didn't understand how big
those platforms were build a good
shopify build a good media plan run good
math many people in the world are good
at math go to sleep it's going to go
back to branding and marketing
and absolute creativity you will have to
get 100 and get them talking about
influencers
starting your own media company
uh
still doing social media marketing but
doing it from a brand standpoint finding
new ways building your own first party
data there's a million things that are
gonna happen it's gonna get harder
for sure and i think the best you know
we talked about this previously but like
this will be like when email just
declined and we just had to figure out
what that next generation is it is there
right it is in new platforms it's in new
ideas like it's there but we're gonna
have to go build it gary this is so much
fun as always
great show thank you so much for having
me as your partner in crime on [ __ ] yeah
fridays on this special thursday which
i'm predicting thursday will get more
juice than people think because we're
both very busy and we just might not
make some fridays in the future so it's
a lot of fun thank you bio entrepreneurs
and friends we are back october 8th uh
next week if you want to apply for the
show go to clear.com
fyf that's [ __ ] yeah fridays for a
chance to be on next week's show i'm
really looking forward to to seeing the
new folks there
cheers youtube watcher what's up it's
garyvee first of all thank you so much i
hope you're doing super well during
these times i also want to ask you
please subscribe because my commitment
and exploration of youtube is about to
explode stories polls more content more
engagement more surprise and delight
this is the time to subscribe i hope you
consider it and i hope i see you soon